-Last night was the big premiere
of "Tick, Tick... Boom!"
here in New York City.
Man, I'm telling you,
oh, my gosh.
We all know how talented you
are, but you can do everything.
-I mean, I don't know about
everything.
But, like, I grew up
doing musical theater.
Like, that is my first passion,
that is my love and my joy,
and nothing fills my heart more
than doing musical theater.
And in the movie, I get to be,
like, Jonathan Larson's backup
vocalist in his one-man play,
"Tick, Tick... Boom!"
So the entire time, I'm
literally just up there, like,
jamming, grooving, supporting
my friend as Vanessa to Andrew,
but also, my character to
Jonathan, it's all very meta,
and it didn't even
feel like work.
-No, but let me tell you,
that scene with
you and Andrew Garfield,
that fast one
where you're both
going and doing...
which must've taken, you know,
23 days just for that one scene.
It's amazing. It's
a showstopper. It is so good.
-Thank you. It's choreographed
down to our eyeballs.
-It actually is.
-Actually.
-You dance with your eyeballs.
-We danced with our eyeballs.
-How did you come across
Lin-Manuel?
He was like, "Oh, we should talk
about a project,"
or did you know him before?
-Yeah, I had met him before.
My first time meeting him,
I went to see "Hamilton."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it was right after --
Yes, of course. We love.
And it was right after I did
"Grease Live!",
and so, Tommy Kail, my director,
his director,
there was like
a little connection.
I walk backstage
and I turn the corner,
and Lin's standing there with
his T-Birds, like, jacket --
leather jacket on, and I'm like,
"Oh, my God, you are
the coolest person ever."
-He's just so fun
and so creative and so positive.
-And so kind.
-And kind too.
-And supportive
and sees everyone.
-I feel like that would be
an amazing director.
-Yeah, the best director
because you feel safe.
Like, every day, he just, like,
shows up and has so much energy,
I don't know where
he gets it from,
because I'm sure he's not
getting a lot of sleep.
-He doesn't stop.
-He would come up to us,
tell us a note,
and be like, "Okay, good? Yeah."
[ Laughter ]
And you're just like, "Oh, we're
doing steps now, okay."
[ Laughter ]
-He would just do fun stuff
like that?
-He would do step routines
all the time,
left, right and center.
-And did you know much of
Jonathan Larson's story?
-I knew, like, a bit, yeah.
Like, I obviously know
"Rent" intimately.
I did it twice.
I played Maureen and Mimi.
-Wow.
-I love his work.
I love his community.
I love his stories, and, like,
he means so much to me
and my friends and my community,
of LGBTQ community
and of the theater.
And it's just, like, it feels
like none of this has been work
because we're talking about
something that is so dear to us.
And it's just like I feel like
I get to be a soldier of love
every day that I show up
talking about this movie.
-Yeah, honestly,
when people see it --
[ Light clapping ]
Please sure.
I mean, it's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's so good.
-I think people will get that.
-Yeah.
-Because, you know, I think
you started maybe
coming on our show back --
It was "High School Musical,"
I want to say.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And then "Princess Switch"
was on Netflix.
That became the biggest thing
in the world.
-Yeah, I have a new one
coming out this Thursday.
-You do?
-Yes, number three.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's still three of me.
-I mean, come on.
-I know, it's crazy.
-But I mean, I don't know,
I just love that you go like --
Usually, if you get one thing
that's a pop culture moment,
it's like, "That's great."
-I know.
-You got two massive ones,
and now, this thing I think is
a whole new career,
and just waking up and going,
"Oh, yeah, she knows
how to do this."
You know how to act,
and you know how to sing,
and when you see it,
it's moving.
The story is amazing.
If you love, just,
I think, like,
the American dream
and the struggle.
-Yeah. And also, like, it
focuses on a group of artists,
but the question that it asks is
universal, which is, "Am I
doing what I should be doing
with the time that I have?"
Because our time really is
so limited and, like,
it makes you be mindful
and really look at yourself
and be like,
"Okay, what are my priorities?"
And that's beautiful.
That's a gift.
-That's exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Vanessa Hudgens
in "Tick, Tick... Boom!"
Take a look.
♪ -If I thought that
what you thought ♪
♪ Was that I hadn't thought
about sharing my thoughts ♪
♪ Then my reaction to
your reaction to my reaction ♪
♪ Would have been
more revealing ♪
-I have been rehearsing all day.
I have been up since 4:00
this morning.
I've been trying to write a song
for a week and I am nowhere!
♪ I was afraid that you would be
afraid if I told you ♪
♪ That I was afraid
of intimacy ♪
-I've been telling you how
unhappy I am for months!
♪ -If you don't have a problem
with my problem ♪
♪ Maybe the problem's
simply co-dependency ♪
Everyone's unhappy in New York!
That's what New York is!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Vanessa Hudgens, everybody!
"Tick, Tick... Boom!"
is in theaters now
and on Netflix this Friday.